ههه صباح الخير ههه
تفضل صح انا بشرب قهوه ما توقعت اللايف
الان فاجئتوني صباح الخير يا اهلا وسهلا
فيكم احنا من الاحساء من هذه المنطقه
الساحره والرائعه بتاريخها اللام المادي
هذا التاريخ الذي من خلاله استطاعته
اليونسكو ان تسجل 65 موقع تراثي في هذه
المدينه والكثير من الاكلات والعادات
والرقصات والطبخات اللذيذه اليوم احنا في
مكان جميل هو كان مزرعه وتم تحويله الى
مطعم
اللقطات لتدخلوا معنا بالاجواء الجميله
هذا المكان كان عباره عن مزرعه ومنزل قديم
تم ترميمه وتجهيزه لان يكون مطعم والكثير
يا نادين وسهام من النزول الريفيه موجوده
في الحساسه اكثر من 1500 نزل ريفي مزارع
وبيوت قديمه تحولت الى مطاعم والى جميله
والى مزارع ورد ومزارع سمسم ومزارع فواكه
وخضروات مفتوحه للزوار وايضا ستكون مفتوحه
لمشجعين كاس العالم للاستمتاع
باجواء الاحساء اليوم احنا مجهزين لكم
شويه اطباق مع الاستاذ يوسف سميح ومختص
بالتراث الحساوي صباح الخير يوسف
عن الاكلات اللي معنا اليوم وعلاقتها
بالتراث الحساوي الممتد من مئات السنين
نبدا مثلا من هنا عندنا هذا المرقوق
المرقوق تمام وعندنا هذا هذا الجنادين
مفلق بالروبيان طيب نحكي عن مثلك ايش
مكوناتها وايش علاقته في التاريخ
دير البحر قريبه البحر وبعدين متخصصين
فيها للحسد بهذه الطريقه هذه وبعدين لو
بدي احط عليه بزينه البيضاوي لابد بيض
حساوي مو بيض الا يكون يعني تربيه بيت ولا
تربيه مزارع هذا مختص في هيك احنا الان
عندنا هنا العصيده العصيده هذا وقت الشتاء
هي العصيده العصيده ما في احلى تمر يحط
لها تمر الاخلاص الحساوي تامر حسام
كل الاكلات الحساويه همم مكوناتها من عرض
الاحسان اكثر
شيء طبيعي كله من الانتاج الحساب اكثر من
الانتاج الحساب
هذا اغلى رز في العالم سهام ونادين لانه
نادر جدا
وعدده قليل جدا كامل الكيلو تقريبا
[موسيقى]
ثلاث مرات لان هنا مثلا 10 كم العادي افضل
رزنديت ولا اي رز مثلا يعتبر هذا ب300
[موسيقى]
نقطه ضعفي الرز الحساوي نادين انا اعشق
هذا الطبق مكوناته
بصل وثوم الحمزه الاولى من مزارع
الانتاج الاحسن اللي هو الحبه الطويله هذا
انتاج الحزم ما ينتاج الا بالحزن
الحساوي لابد منك وتحتاج الى حاجه واحده
بس وانا مثلج او هذا احنا اهل الحاسه بصل
اسم البصل الحساوي حبه طويله بيقطعونه
صغار وبيفرقونه مع البهارات مع ليمون
وسط الاكل بيحط في وسط الاكل
الحساوي في طاقه فيه بروتينات في همم
فيتامينز كثيره لانه المزارعين سابقا
فكانوا يحتاجون الى اكيد
جدا جدا
طحين طحين
اوكي
من الطحين والتمر والتمر
بس ما شاء الله يعني يطلع لك شيء مميز
والخبز الاحمر بالنسبه الي لونه
[موسيقى]
جديد
شكرا جزيلا لك